des agents de sécurité de plus en plus
recherchés avec la mise en place du pass
sanitaire commerce et collectivités font
appel à des sociétés pour engager du
personnel supplémentaire
une augmentation de la demande parfois
difficile à assurer pour les entreprises
spécialisées
c'est le cas de la société épi ouest qui
opèrent en bretagne à la recherche de 25
agents soit une augmentation de plus
d'un tiers de son effectif un
recrutement parfois compliqué dans un
secteur déjà à flux tendu trouver du
monde oui c'est compliqué on se rend
compte qu'elle était une pénurie ou
pénurie d'agents sur la région
maintenant on arrive toujours à trouver
plus ou moins du personnel on va dire
que le roi flux tendu mais oui sursis
cette mission devait être amenée à
perdurer wii est toujours en évolution
perpétuelle
oui on aurait on va avoir un peu plus de
mal chaque jour et chaque chaque mois
qui passe à à pouvoir fournir l'ensemble
des prestations demandées par nos
clients la demande l'agent de sécurité
s'est notamment renforcé pour les
restaurants et les salles de spectacle
fermée depuis le 27 octobre dernier ce
cabaret situé à une quinzaine de
kilomètres de rennes prépare sa
réouverture en plus d'un salarié détaché
au contrôle des passes annie terre pour
les groupes il faut un agent de sécurité
pour rassurer celui des clients
particuliers une charge supplémentaire à
assumer ça décuple tout en fait
qui plus est ça nous avec le staff qu'on
a déjà à l'intérieur ça sollicite
quelqu'un de plus aussi au niveau du
vagin du service et c'est donc forcément
il faut décupler les équipes fois c'est
une charge en plus pour nous cette
vérification
c'est pas la main c'est pas le virus en
soit c'est l'organisation derrière le
protocole à appliquer pour faire face à
la demande les professionnels du secteur
de la sécurité ont demandé au
gouvernement une évolution de la
réglementation
ils réclament notamment la création d'un
statut d'adjoint de sécurité
afin de faciliter le recrutement de
personnel